at the end of the day life is about
being happy being
who you are and i feel like we are so
blessed to have the best support system
and the best family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through kim
kardashian and kanye west are getting
away
and enjoying some much-needed family
time i love that
the source tells et that the couple is
currently together
outside the u.s spending time with their
kids
and adds that the decision came after
kim saw kanye in wyoming last week
the reality star's emotional visit to
see her husband
marked the first time they were able to
see each other
after kanye's controversial political
rally in south carolina
she brought north into the world even
when i didn't want to
she stood up and she protected that
child and his subsequent twitter storm
of now deleted tweets about kim and her
famous family
he might say things that might get
misinterpreted and people don't see the
context behind it but i always know his
heart
as for why the west decided to jet out
of town
well e.t source says it's because the
couple knows they need quality time with
their kids
and no other outside voices or people
quote kim knows that kanye being with
his family will be good for him
i've seen him go through a lot and he's
just the most
genuine person
meanwhile kim's younger sister chloe has
been working on her relationship with
tristan thompson
tristan's been really consistent and
present
and that's great in fact a source
confirms to et the couple is officially
back together
and says things are going really well
quote chloe is doing what she feels is
right for herself
and her daughter true i'm just super
happy and content and i'm focused on
work and like taking care of me my body
and soul and
true and yeah we know what you're
thinking what about that whole tristan
and jordan woods cheating scandal he did
kiss me
my family was ruined tristan
might love me whatever that means he has
no respect for me whatsoever
well guys that's a thing of the past
it's just you know things happen and of
course
i'm sorry and apologetic as much as i
can be it's
just i think a little too toxic for me
to keep reliving stuff like that
our source says that chloe has never
listened to any outside voices or
opinions i think this is a part of
life i'm not saying it was unfortunate
yeah coco is taking this time to really
connect with her man
and staying true to her heart
[Music]
you